Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
is now trying to cut LGBT subject matter
from an advanced placement psychology
class that is taught in Florida as an
optional class and the College Board
good for them is saying no the bigger
story here well there's really two
stories here there's three stories
there's 12 no there's three as far as I
can tell one is the subject matter in
the curriculum of this advanced
placement psychology class which we'll
talk about in a moment the second part
of it is the continued quote anti-woke
war that Ron DeSantis is fighting in the
State of Florida and thirdly is that
this is yet another example of how
right-wingers claim to have a particular
value but then as soon as that value is
inconvenient they abandon it and I will
tell you about that in a moment and it
has everything to do with this subject
matter being in a psychology class which
based on their previous statements is
something you would think they would be
okay with so let's go to the beginning
what is going on USA Today reports Ron
DeSantis wants to scrub AP classes of
lgbtq subjects the College Board isn't
having it and uh it says another
Showdown over advanced placement courses
could be brewing in Florida this time
over AP psychology as the non-profit
that runs the program the College Board
faces pressure from State officials to
remove or revise lessons on sexual
orientation and gender identity the
conflict is another example of how
DeSantis is pushed to restrict how race
and lgbtq issues are taught is impacting
Florida schools Florida's Department of
Education sent a letter to the College
Board asking them to review all AP
courses to see if they need modification
to ensure compliance with a Florida law
that targets instruction on sexual
orientation and gender identity the
message is clear
remove that stuff the College Board
responded with a defiant letter late
last week saying we will not modify our
courses to accommodate restrictions
teaching essential college level topics
this could be a showdown and this class
could become a source of conflict the
hill also reporting college board says
it won't alter AP courses to comply with
Florida laws they put out a letter
saying that this is not something that
they are going to do adding doing so
would break the fundamental promise of
advanced placement colleges wouldn't
broadly accept the course for credit and
that course wouldn't prepare students
for careers in the discipline so let's
talk about what it is that is going on
here first of all this is you know as
usual the way that the anti-woke Florida
people want to frame these stories are
this is extremely inappropriate stuff
being taught to kids the reality of
course is that this is and advanced
placement class it's overwhelmingly High
School seniors
and some high school juniors
occasionally a sophomore if they're a
real go-getter you know what I mean but
it's overwhelmingly seniors and juniors
who are either this year or next year
going to be adults it is an optional
class relatively few people take
advanced placement classes I'm not
saying oh the raw number is low but
relatively few people take these classes
when I took AP economics in high school
that was the one AP class I took it
represents it was 12 students out of 900
or something like that uh and that was
it so nothing is being pushed on anybody
these are almost legal adults and most
importantly and this is the point the
College Board is making AP level classes
are
equivalent to college classes you
sometimes get credit I was able to skip
right to uh intro to macroeconomics with
Richard Wolff by the way at the
University of Massachusetts my first
semester because I got credit for AP
micro from high school so if you
arbitrarily say we're going to change
around what's in this class the class is
designed to be a college equivalency
class in college in Psychology class
lgbtq issues are part of the subject
matter if you arbitrarily remove that
from the AP High School class you
endanger that class actually being a
college equivalency class so it is
undeniably now let me get now to this
next issue so first and foremost doesn't
make any sense to remove it makes
perfect sense to have this content there
uh if you are a right winger now I I
what this is an if okay we're doing
abstract thinking if you are one of the
right Wingers who writes to me and says
David whether it's trans even if it's
gay all of this stuff is merely mental
illness there's no biological basis for
lgbtq it's just mental illness by that
standard a psychology class is the
correct place for this subject matter
this is a college equivalent psychology
class I'm not supporting this view but
what I'm saying is if you have the view
that lgbtq issues are merely issues of
mental health that should not be taught
to quote kids
then what better place for them than in
a college equivalent psychology class
another reminder that they don't
actually mean the things they say they
love saying these subjects shouldn't be
in science class they shouldn't be in
Biology class well maybe they should or
maybe they shouldn't it's quite a large
amount of scholarship on that but if
they shouldn't and you believe these are
simply mental illnesses then if not in a
college equivalent psychology course
where the hell do you put this subject
matter so there's two different views on
what DeSantis is doing here it's mere
pandering to continue this veneer of an
anti-woke warrior in Florida who will
bring that anti-woke perspective to the
Oval Office if he is elected I don't
know that it's just pandering because
this is actual uh legislative this there
is plenty of legislation that DeSantis
has actually signed into law these
haven't just been PR battles that go
along these lines they hate legislation
in Florida under DeSantis has been going
on for a period of time now that there
may be a pandering element to it but it
is much more than mere pandering that we
can write off so that's the latest
battle by the way I will restate this
doesn't overall I mean listen Maybe you
get away with this a lot of people won't
even hear about this a lot of these
things the hardcore anti-woke trans
stuff the abortion restrictions fighting
Disney there actually doesn't seem to be
that much of an appetite for this
nationally and it may end up hurting
DeSantis or at least not helping him
catch up to Donald Trump which is at the
end of the day what he needs to do right
now in the Republican primary all right
I now am glad I genuinely am glad
to be able to do what so many of you
delightful Mega people have been telling
me I should do talk about the Biden
crimes talk about the Biden crimes let's
talk about them Donald Trump was
indicted on 34 37 felony counts last
week and on that day you had Fox with a
front page headline about the Biden
bribery and you had Trump speaking at
Bedminster talking about Biden's
documents and all of these different
things so let's talk a little bit about
it we're going to talk about later about
some of the allegations made by
Republicans that Joe Biden has committed
crimes
that doesn't really sound like due
process to me but we'll get that to that
in a moment but let's talk about the new
bombshell about Biden bribery if you
actually question Republicans
specifically about what they are
alleging here
you get them mostly to admit
they don't know whether the Biden
bribery tapes actually exist they
haven't spoken to one of the main people
making these allegations in three years
even those who are sure the tapes exist
say they actually don't know if they are
reputable or trustworthy so let's talk
about Biden bribery and you were very
quickly going to realize as of right now
there isn't anything that we would call
evidence on the day of Trump's
indictment so many of you wrote to me
and said why won't I talk about this
well it's not that I won't talk about it
it's that we actually need to know is
there anything worthy of talking about
here is Republican Congressman James
Comer not sandbagged by some left-wing
interviewer but interviewed on Newsmax
and he says the tapes the tapes
everybody is building this case around
he's not even sure if those tapes are
legitimate when will you be able to
confirm if these recordings are legit
how long is that going to take
well I can confirm that the recordings
we're in a 10 23. remember I was okay
let's pause it right there
the 1023 the 1023 they are referring to
is a form that asserts the existence of
such tapes it is not evidence of the
tapes what he says is the form mentions
the tapes
that's like if I make a statement and I
I could write down on this piece of
paper down here that Hunter Biden's
laptop is actually you know a Nintendo
Wii the fact that I've written it down
doesn't mean that it is true okay but
let's continue Senator Grassley when we
saw the unredacted version okay so Chris
Grassley was saying alleged yesterday so
these recordings are legit you can
confirm they are legitimate they were I
can confirm they were listed in the 1023
you understand that right he he he can't
confirm that these recordings are
legitimate he can just say they are
referred to on a piece of paper the FBI
redacted we don't know if they're legit
or not but we know that the foreign
National claims he has them exactly we
don't know if they are legitimate this
is the Blockbuster that so many of our
Mega viewers are saying I'm ignoring
okay here is James Comer saying they
haven't heard from the so-called major
witness in three years with respect to
the tapes look it mentioned in the FBI
form that the oligarch had 17 tapes of
Biden two with Joe Biden except in the
bride that he used that as an insurance
this Oliver is a high-ranking was a
high-ranking member uh or owner of
barisma
yes that is exactly right so have you
had anything can you show them
unfortunately nobody's had any contact
with him for the last three years
[Laughter]
okay so the Blockbuster that I ignored
on the day Trump was indicted in an
extraordinarily detailed and tight
indictment per Chris Christie that that
day I am guilty of ignoring the
Blockbuster story in which a supposed
Russian oligarch
who hasn't been heard from for three
years
asserted according to a 1023 form that
he has tapes which we don't know exist
and even if they exist we don't know if
they are legitimate tapes here's
Marjorie Taylor green also admitting it
the audio is poor she's speaking to
CNN's Manu Raju here but listen closely
to what she says
okay so she first says these audio
recordings that were made are a really
big deal
now does the guy have the audio
recordings I don't know and I don't
think we're going to find out wow that
is really quite a story Marjorie really
really unbelievable uh and then when you
actually go through a lot of the
reporting on this you see that there is
a lot of uh shakiness shakiness uh The
Daily Beast reporting Republicans admit
they don't know if the Biden bribery
tapes really exist Newsmax had an
article earlier this week of Congressman
Waltz saying that a blind eye is being
turned to the Biden documents we're not
even really sure that the Biden
documents refer to things that exist you
have an article from the New York Post
in alleged Biden bribe scheme claims to
have 15 taped conversations with Hunter
and two with Joe according to Chuck
Grassley is Chuck Grassley telling the
truth is the guy actually a barisma boss
did he actually claim to have those
tapes do the tapes exist are the tapes
legitimate do the tapes even expose the
alleged criminality they claim is there
and then also Fox news reporting barisma
audio tapes could be
could be a cataclysmic event for
President Biden according to Trump's
completely weaponized delusional former
acting AG Matt Whittaker there is very
little here my friends the hunter Biden
laptop okay the laptop maybe is real
there were three MacBooks dropped off by
someone to a Blind repair man who
couldn't actually see whose they were
but he saw a sticker on one of the
MacBooks for Beau Biden's charity and
said this is Hunter Biden's laptop it
didn't really contain much other than
some extraordinarily vague
unsubstantiated reference and explicit
pictures of Hunter Biden himself
not exactly a major Blockbuster story
The Biden bribery tapes do they actually
exist we don't really know right now the
Biden quote classified document Scandal
let's suspend that one for now because
I'll dig into it a little bit later and
then Hillary's crimes of course she was
cleared of criminal wrongdoing and we'll
talk about that later the one thing out
of all of this that I can tell you is
real is that there is a real 37 count
federal felony indictment against Donald
Trump it contains photographic evidence
it refers to audio recordings it is
extraordinarily tight according to Chris
Christie that is real that we know
exists but these Maga people keep
writing to me and saying David you're
not willing to talk about XYZ I'm glad
to talk about it when I have time like
today there's just really not that much
to say about it and that's the reason
I'm not giving it more coverage
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
remember that the David pakman show is
an audience supported program we're
really a community funded show unlike so
many of those other right wing and even
some Centrist and center-left media
Outlets we really depend primarily on
your support you can sign up at
joinpakman.com we really do put in a lot
of effort both technologically and in
terms of Staff time into providing great
perks for our members including
commercial free audio and video streams
of everyday's show an extra program
every weekday called the bonus show
access to a soundboard that works like
my soundboard here oh the bonus show
where you
yeah everybody also makes money to fund
themselves as bad we have a soundboard
like that software version available in
the membership portion of the website as
well as invites to member only Town
Halls you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and of course use the now Infamous
coupon code indicted again all right
listen I think we're doing something
good today we talked about Biden's
bribery we we're going to talk now about
Hillary's emails we're going to talk
about Joe Biden's classified documents I
think that while
you and I mostly understand that these
are red herrings and what about ISM from
the right it's not a bad thing when we
have the opportunity to put on the
record everything we know about these
situations so we can refer back to it so
I'm going to give you a couple of
examples here of incredible what about
ISM from right Wingers here is for
example Ron DeSantis interestingly
enough defending Donald Trump against
his recent indictment by immediately
bringing up Hillary Clinton's emails I
know it's satirical in almost a parody
at this point that you ask about a real
37 felony count indictment with pictures
with evidence with Witnesses and they
say well what about Hillary's emails for
which she's been cleared of criminal
wrongdoing but that's what they want to
do here's Ron DeSantis when I was uh uh
in Congress I remember you know Hillary
had the the emails with the classified
and my view was well gee you know as a
naval officer if I would have taken
classified to my apartment I would have
been court-martialed in a New York
minute and yet they seem to not care
care about that and is there a different
standard for a Democrat Secretary of
State versus a former Republican
president I think there needs to be one
standard of Justice in this country
right and that standard of justice is if
there is evidence of criminality
regardless of who you are you get
yourself indicted it's actually sort of
shocking that they're still doing this
and it's not just Ron DeSantis here's
another example here's Republican
Congressman Mike Waltz who again in an
attempt to defend Trump says listen you
can call it what about ISM and then he
brings up Hillary Clinton's email why
not just hand them over if to your point
this happens a lot yeah well look under
if he believed he was privileged on the
the presidential records act then that
is a conversation that I would argue
should have continued to happen because
what's missing also in this conversation
and I can tell you this talking to
Floridians and and folks back home you
can call it what about what about ISM or
and we will because that's what it is
what have you they're calling it
fairness uh and there's legal precedent
here when you have the Clinton tapes
when you have the Clinton emails when
you have the fact that the sitting
National Security advisor right now Jake
Sullivan
was sending and laundering classified
documents into an unclassified server on
top of the fact that the sitting
president of the United States admitted
he had documents in his garage that
you're going in and out of people look
at that and say whoa wait a minute
there was prosecutorial discretion there
they didn't prosecute they didn't go
after these folks and all of these other
instances all right you get the point
this actually makes no sense but sense
in the facts don't matter so it in a
sense makes perfect sense that they are
doing something that makes no sense
Donald Trump's indictment is based on 37
felony counts related to mishandling
classified documents obstructing justice
making false statements some of those
actions under the Espionage Act which we
will dig into later as we continue our
Deep dive into this the Hillary Clinton
email controversy was based on
allegations that she used a private
email server for public Communications
this was deemed extremely careless by
the FBI it was not deemed Criminal by
the FBI because it did not appear to
break the law that's what we care about
the Trump indictment says Trump shared a
classified map
related to military operations uh with
people who were not qualified to see
that he knew that it wasn't Declassified
because he said after leaving office
this is classified he improperly stored
boxes containing classified documents by
his toilet in the Ballroom in the shower
he went out of his way to avoid giving
back the documents Hillary Clinton's
email controversy involved emails that
were retroactively classified by the
state department after they were sent or
received an important detail none of
them were marked classified at the time
the Trump indictment alleges Trump got
numerous requests from the justice
department saying just hand the stuff
over hand it over and he didn't do it
the allegations against Trump include
making false statements to the FBI going
to his aides and lawyers and saying Help
Me Lie help me hide help me do
everything to avoid giving these
documents back in the Hillary Clinton
situation Nation she immediately and
voluntarily handed over about thirty
thousand emails to the state department
that were work related and deleted about
thirty thousand personal emails she
deemed irrelevant the right likes to say
well the thirty thousand emails she
deemed irrelevant weren't irrelevant
okay well the investigation hasn't
determined that that's the case the
Trump indictment could result in prison
time for him and Walt nauda who is a
co-conspirator and was also indicted the
Hillary Clinton email controversy was
fully investigated and the determination
was there was not a crime committed and
so charges were not filed the right says
that's because of political bias there
is no evidence of that because the
things Hillary did and what Trump is
accused of are dramatically different so
that's Hillary's emails let's now look
at the Joe Biden part a little bit more
closely Elise stefanik who is an
absolutely horrible Republican member of
Congress went on Fox News and remember
due process law and auto Law and Order
whatever they call it these days she
went on Fox News and said I believe Joe
Biden committed multiple criminal acts
really wow based on what evidence and
you have them trying to protect Joe
Biden who has I believe committed
multiple criminal acts there's going to
come to a point where they're going to
have to report on it absolutely all
right thank you so much chairwoman for
coming thank you by the way not going to
ask a question about is that due process
is that Law and Order Elise I believe
that the president has committed
multiple criminal acts although I have
no evidence so let's now dig into this
one and then we're going to really be
able to say we did it and I don't want
to hear any more from the Maga people
the insistence that Joe Biden
is a crook
is not backed by any evidence at this
point in time they say it
to try to counter balance
documentary
photographic and sworn eyewitness
evidence of Donald Trump's criminality
Trump is innocent until proven guilty
but there's an indictment based on 37
felony counts mishandling obstructing
making false statements Etc the Biden
classified documents incident is based
on the discovery of a few dozen
classified documents some from when
Biden was in the Senate some from the
era of the Obama Administration at
Biden's uh former office and home
there's a special counsel investigating
it the Special counsel hasn't finished
yet I'm fine saying if the special
counsel finds evidence that Joe Biden
did something illegal then charge the
guy however that's not actually the path
that that investigation is going and
we're going to get to that in a moment
Trump's indictment says he was sharing
classified documents as I said with
people who weren't authorized to see
them improperly storing them directing
lawyers and aides to lie and hide and
obstruct and Destroy he had toilet
documents a huge dump of documents right
by his toilet all these different things
Biden's document incident involves
records that were inadvertently
misplaced in a locked closet at his
former office and some in his garage at
home the White House has said as soon as
we figured that out we immediately
turned it over and have been cooperating
fully with the doj that is not what
Donald Trump did and much of what Trump
is charged with is in that aftermath
it's the cover-up for lack of a better
term Trump defied requests as I told you
made false statements as I told you told
aids to hide and obstruct as I told you
Biden's classified documents don't
involve a single allegation of lying or
a single allegation of obstruction of
justice why because Biden didn't do
those things he's been he has not been
accused of any wrongdoing or charged at
this time Trump's indictment could
result in prison time we don't know yet
but it could Biden's classified document
incident by all legal assessments that
make sense not by Mark Levin or Tom
fitton but by people who actually are
taking this seriously Biden's
consequences could be administrative
sanctions or in theory he could have his
security clearance revoked even though
he's president if it finds if the
investigation finds that he was
negligent or behaved improperly then of
course we have the Biden bribery stuff I
already talked about Biden bribery
earlier so we've now looked at Biden
bribery we've looked at Biden classified
documents we've looked at Hillary
classified documents we've done it all
okay if anybody is found to have likely
committed a crime I'm the first to say
charge them but it would be wrong for me
to tell you that that's the direction
these things are pointing those are the
facts no matter how many times Mega
trumpists starts screaming about it
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's continue some explanatory
discussions of some of what has been
circulating in the news for the last
week or so we took calls on the Friday
show at the end of last week the way we
always do and a caller called in talking
to me about the Espionage Act and the
fact that failed twice indicted twice
impeached former president Donald Trump
was partially charged under the
Espionage Act in this latest round of
indictments and sort of see seem to be
implying by his questions that if you're
charged under the Espionage Act you were
being accused of being a foreign spy in
some way shape or form and of course I
explained that that's not the case and I
want to delve into that a little bit
more today the Espionage Act is a law
that says you can't keep or share secret
information that belongs to the
government without permission if you do
you could end up in prison and the law
was made a while ago it's still used
today there are some who say it is
sometimes used improperly or uh applied
incorrectly but it is not unusual that
it is used to prosecute individuals who
are not quite literally spies and that
is exactly what is going on here Trump
also made similar claims
during that speech at Bedminster sort of
saying they're charging me under the
Espionage Act Like I did XYZ but I just
had some papers and it's really not even
a criminal issue at all he claims so a
couple of important places to start and
then we're going to talk about some
examples the Espionage Act is not for
spies who help other countries only it's
for people who keep secret papers
without permission it's for people who
refuse to turn over secret and
classified documents that they have it's
for people who obstruct the government's
attempt to recover documents that
remember belong to them to the
government rather not to the individuals
that are holding them even while Trump
was President many non-spies were
charged under this law and Trump didn't
have any problem with that at those
cases so we've got a bunch of examples
here this is from a CNN article Robert
Burcham uh Air Force Lieutenant Colonel
a long career in the first month of the
Trump presidency the government figured
out this guy had more than 300
classified documents or files in his
home he had a storage pod and uh some of
the documents were there he wasn't
charged with spying he wasn't charged
with giving the documents to people he
cooperated and he was indeed prosecuted
under the Espionage Act doesn't mean he
spied for a foreign country Kendra
Kingsbury analyst for the FBI indicted
in 2021 for possessing classified
documents in her home during the time
that Trump was president again a similar
situation uh not really controversial in
terms of the use of the Espionage Act
there Jeremy Brown retired army Special
Forces Sergeant became involved with
far-right group The Oath Keepers
convicted last year for possession of
unregistered grenades and guns and for
violating willful retention of National
Defense information Provisions he was
found to have documents and he was
charged on that basis and then there's
other examples okay Harold Martin and
Ahmed delhadi Yasin zaralgadin
Weldon Marshall Marshall uh gefa there's
all of these examples so this is not a
unique or unusual thing you aren't
required to be spying for a foreign
country in order to be charged under the
Espionage Act the papers belong to the
government not to Trump and this is a
critical distinction or detail that
needs to be understood there was this
kind of flippant attitude from Trump
during his speech at Bedminster where he
said these are my documents it's
unilaterally my choice what to do with
them etc etc he misstated how the
presidential records act Works he
misstated the timing suggesting that
he's actually being charged for things
he did as president when he's being
charged for his actions after leaving
the Oval Office but he acted as if these
are his documents when they are not the
shirts that he claimed the mementos or
for whatever reason they seem to call
them momentos I don't know how the Right
comes up with this stuff the word is
mementos but he said I had all sorts of
mementos shirts and and sports balls and
different things the papers belong to
the government and slash to the American
people depending on how you want to say
it and Trump lied he tried to hide them
from investigators Etc so now you have a
situation where Trump could face prison
time if he's found guilty we'll talk
about the prison time a little bit later
uh and it is not improper to use the
Espionage Act have there been
problematic uses of the Espionage Act in
the past sure
uh are all uses of the Espionage Act
problematic no is it the law yes it is
so in addition to this it's important to
mention Trump hasn't been charged for
what I'm about to tell you but you know
so you always want to go through every
layer uh why charge Trump under the
Espionage Act if he wasn't spying for
another country well that's not what the
Espionage Act is but it is important to
mention Trump has done some pretty
sketchy stuff with regard to foreign
powers many of you will remember the
infamous incident in 2017 when he had
the Russian foreign minister Sergey
lavrov and Russian Ambassador Sergey
kislyak a widely known spy recruiter for
Russia in the Oval Office and Trump
shared with them information given to us
in confidence by our Ally Israel now you
might say I hate Israel okay but fine it
doesn't change the fact that Trump
unilaterally sharing secrets from allies
isn't a good thing and is
extraordinarily problematic from a
national security perspective number two
Trump tweeted a classified image of
damage to an Iranian Spaceport in 2019.
Trump told Filipino president Rodrigo
duterte about two nuclear subs that the
U.S had off the coast of North Korea he
wasn't supposed to say that that's not
something he was supposed to be talking
about he almost certainly gave sensitive
information if not classified to Russian
president President Vladimir Putin
during the G20 in Germany in 2017
and then Trump confiscated the
interpreter's notes about the
conversation very very very unusual and
fifth you might remember when Trump
posted videos to twitter or a video to
Twitter of several members of Seal Team
five in camo and night vision goggles
revealing where they were and with
unblurred faces he's not being charged
for any of those things
and the Espionage Act doesn't have to be
used only for issues related to spying
for foreign countries but the point is
Trump also does have a history
of being at minimum careless is where I
would feel confident saying at minimum
careless with the sensitive information
he shares with foreign leaders including
adversarial ones now all of that being
said
let's have a sober conversation about
how much prison time Donald Trump is
really facing
let's contextualize the Trump prison
time discussion on the one hand there
are headlines about Trump is facing 536
years on the other hand you have
individuals who say there is no time in
prison coming for Donald Trump my
personal opinion this is now not we're
not doing legal now now I'm just giving
you my personal opinion
two weeks ago I was convinced Trump
would get no prison time I now think it
is very likely Trump will get no prison
time but that's a bit of a softening I
am now open to the idea that depending
on how this federal trial goes it's at
least conceivable Trump might end up
getting sentenced to some prison time
now let's take my opinion out of it and
let's talk about sentencing guidelines
and the crimes that Trump is accused of
having committed
536 years is one of these listen if you
take every crime individually
and you look at the maximum possible
sentence assuming he was convicted of
every crime he's charged with that no
crimes are Consolidated or grouped
together and that he gets the maximum a
consecutive rather than concurrent
sentence for each of those crimes that's
how you get that top number 536. uh but
the more realistic number is far lower
and I want to explain to you why if you
look at the crimes that Trump is charged
with he's accused of giving or trying to
give uh um uh show I guess you would say
classified information to people who
were not actually authorized to see that
stuff
um there are obstruction charges there
are all sorts of different charges that
that are that are here and the most he
could get for the heaviest charges would
be 5 to 20 years per charge but the
actual prison time would depend on a lot
of different factors what are the goals
of the punishment meant how does this
actually go if a trial comes or if a
plea deal is accepted or whatever the
case may be when judges are to decide
how much prison time they will give
someone particularly when you are
talking about these multiple you know
dozens of counts Federal trials there
are sentencing guidelines and sentencing
guidelines at least in an Ideal World or
based on the effects of the crimes that
individuals have been convicted of
research data questions about recidivism
uh how victims were affected the role
that the individual played in a crime so
you might have like for example
a crime around someone's death but
depending on the role of the individual
they might not be charged with murder
they might be charged with something
else okay so the a lot of different
things as well as was this a guilty plea
where the person accepted responsibility
did they fight it in a trial and were
subsequently found guilty all of these
different uh elements are factors and
the guidelines assign a number to each
factor reflecting how serious it is and
this this is includes what are the
crimes as well as the circumstances
surrounding it and you add that all up
and it gives you an offense level the
higher the offense level the more severe
the crime and the circumstances and
aggravating factors and presumably the
longer the prison time is going to be
and so there's an article that tries to
sort of look at this the article is on
the just security website it's called
how much prison time does former
president Trump face applying U.S
sentencing guidelines and if you go
through it I'll kind of just like uh
shortcut it for you the article adds up
everything and gets a total offense
level
that would signal somewhere between
253 and 293 months in prison for Donald
Trump that's 20 to 24 years for an
individual who has no previous crimes on
their record
that's like a starting point to get us a
ballpark this is only an estimate and
many things could change this first of
all there could be more charges against
Trump or some charges could be
Consolidated and eliminated evidence or
facts could come forward Trump might get
sentenced on multiple accounts at once
Trump might only be found guilty or
might only plea to certain crimes he
could be acquitted altogether obviously
all of these different factors the
general idea is if Trump were found
guilty
of most of the things he's charged with
realistically you would start with a
top-line sentence of 20 to 24 years
these are only guidelines they're not
mandatory judges can choose to go with
different prison time based on a lot of
other different factors and of course
listen everything we know about Trump
right now is he's not going to take a
plea deal he's going to fight this fight
this fight this even when people come to
Trump and say hey this is your best path
forward if it doesn't have the right
Optics Trump rejects it I'll give you an
example of that later on in the show we
would probably only see a departure
below that at the end of the day is it
possible that Trump is convicted of or
pleads guilty to something but ends up
with only a symbolic sentence uh maybe
even a suspended sentence or home
confinement we're talking about a former
president here and all of those
circumstances are 100 possibilities at
this point we are only starting to get
into this and this also doesn't even
consider
what about the New York indictment what
about a possible second Federal
indictment what about the possible
indictment coming out of Georgia if you
think about the totality the seriousness
of the crimes in the Federal indictment
the possibility of trump facing three or
four different indictments it sort of
feels like that could very likely point
to some prison time at the same time
we're talking about a former president
nearly 80 years old with a lot of at
least plausible mitigating circumstances
his lawyers could argue including age
and security issues with Trump serving
even a single day and so we may end up
with some symbolic home confinement we
are all getting ahead of ourselves I
believe in Law and Order so I don't want
anybody sentenced to anything until
they've been found guilty or have pled
guilty to something in a plea deal and
so I'm not going to get ahead of myself
this is all hypothetical and obviously
it's going to be one of the biggest
stories of the next couple of years
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
by now I'm sure most of you know that
this entire Federal prosecution of
Donald Trump didn't have to go this way
but what I mean by that is different
than what we're going to talk about
right now in general when we say it
didn't have to go this way we all
understand any other normal person when
uh authorities come to you and say hey
you took all this stuff you got to give
it back and then they ask you again and
again and they send letters and they
send people and meet with you and say
you've got to give it back most of us
would say here take this stuff back and
in that sense this never had to go this
way but there's a new report about an
even more relevant and pressing way in
which it didn't have to go this way it
is being reported by The Washington Post
that Donald Trump
rejected his lawyers efforts to avoid
the indictment from happening in the
first place and this truly is classic
Trump and it tells us a lot about how
the next several months into the next 18
to 24 months quite frankly are likely to
go let's take a look at this this is a
great report by Josh dossey and
Jacqueline Alemany Trump rejected
lawyers efforts to avoid classified
documents indictment the former
president was not interested in
attempting to negotiate a settlement in
the classified documents investigation
one of Donald Trump's new attorneys
proposed an idea in the fall of 2022.
this is months ago now months ago the
former president's team could try to
arrange a settlement with the justice
department the attorney Christopher keis
wanted to quietly approach Justice to
see if he could negotiate a settlement
that would preclude charges hoping
attorney general Merritt Garland in the
department would want an exit ramp to
avoid avoid Prosecuting a former
president Keys could would hopefully
take the temperature down he was telling
others by promising a professional
approach and the return of all documents
but Trump was not interested after
listening to other lawyers who urged a
more pugilistic approach just wait until
you hear who those lawyers were the
article goes on so Keys Never approached
prosecutors according to three people
briefed on the matter a special counsel
was appointed months later the rest is
history as we now know Keys a former
solicitor general of Florida who was
paid three million dollars up front to
join Trump's team last year declined to
comment that quiet entreaty last fall
was one of many occasions when lawyers
and advisors sought to get Trump to take
a more Cooperative stance in a bid to
avoid what happened Friday the justice
department unsealed an indictment
including more than three dozen criminal
counts as we now know Trump's 77 years
old now faces the most legal legally
perilous moment of his life playing out
in federal court charges that could
bring decades in prison as we talked
about in the previous segment the
article goes on to explain how Trump's
claim that this is only under the
presidential records Act is wrong this
now has become a criminal matter
um also in a Vanity Fair best Levin
writes report Donald Trump passed on a
plan to avoid criminal charges and now
he's facing up to 400 years in prison
and it's basically a rewrite of much of
the same stuff that we just talked about
this is classic Trump okay we have since
learned that one of the people
suggesting to Trump take a more
combative approach take a more
pugilistic approach was this guy named
Tom fitton from this right-wing group
called Judicial Watch not a working
lawyer in the sense of criminal defense
who would be able to give Trump anything
approaching sensible advice on this
particular matter classic Trump you've
got a bunch of lawyers it's not just
Christopher Keys a bunch of lawyers who
are going through
who actually know what they're doing and
they're saying listen this is serious
why don't we approach them and say hey
we don't want this to get to an
indictment let's figure this out now
that we have the right people around
Trump we can get you the document in a
professional and sober way you're not
going to have to indict Trump and by the
way everything that we saw from Merit
Garland over the last couple of years is
that he didn't want to have Trump
indicted uh there were some criticizing
Garland saying this guy's not even
willing to indict Trump he just it's
just not even a chance I never went that
far but it certainly seemed like it
wasn't something Garland was looking to
do but the more we learn about the
goings-on of the last seven eight months
the more it seems as though Trump's
refusal to take a less combative
approach in a sense Force the hand of
Merit Garland and there's a very good
write-up that we already looked at
in the last segment about how Federal
sentencing guidelines could be applied
those Federal sentencing guidelines I'm
not going to redo that segment because
we did it 10 minutes ago on the show
they point to something like 20 to 24
years based on sentencing guidelines
severity of crimes how they likely uh be
sentenced and Trump being a first-time
offender at least technically speaking
so on and so forth and um the estimate
also now adds that if Trump were to take
responsibility it might cut it down by
about a third I don't think Trump is
going to be doing any of those things so
this is on brand for Trump when you look
at even the Mueller probe into Russia uh
stuff
much of the way it went down was a
direct result of the way in which Trump
didn't just shut up and say hey I'm
president now I'm running the country
there's an investigation I won't
interfere I will cooperate but I will be
saying nothing else publicly about it
had Trump done that at the start of the
Mueller probe 90 of it wouldn't have
taken place it would have wrapped much
more quickly and it likely would not
have brought down as many people as it
did
instead Trump was tweeting about it
daily making comments during press
conferences making attacks on on Mueller
and investigators and actually giving
new leads to investigators about things
that they should be looking at so it was
self-inflicted this may end up being we
don't know we're speculating this may
end up being the greatest example in
Trump's life of opting for a path
because of his personality because of
his ego because of his narcissism or
whatever this may be the single decision
Trump made which is to say to his
lawyers don't go in and negotiate me out
of an indictment this may be the
decision that ends Trump's public life
it may not be but it may and we're going
to continue following it let's now
discuss what the next 18 months are
going to look like for the American
political system last week I did a
segment
uh for our Tick Tock account which by
the way Tick Tock over 500 000 followers
on Tick Tock it's crazy what's going on
we're reaching young people we're wild
things are happening on Tick Tock I did
a segment where I laid out why I don't
think the impact of Trump's arrest will
be limited only to the presidential race
and the point I made was that there's
going to be a significant trickle-down
effect now I'm wondering whether I did
this for tick tock or for our straight
arrow news partnership but in any case I
do remember talking about this maybe
even on the bonus show now I don't
remember
my argument is as follows it would be
wrong to assume that Trump's trials and
indictments will only affect the
presidential race I believe that it will
affect down ballot Republicans and it
has the potential depending on how this
all goes over the next six to 18 months
to generate an insane amount of chaos
for Republicans trying to get themselves
re-elected in November of 2024. if you
are a pro-trump Acolyte and you're
trying to get reelected and Trump really
has legal issues and is damaged in the
primary maybe loses it or wins but then
loses to Joe Biden
it could turn off a lot of people from
voting for their local elected official
house or senate for re-election on the
other hand if you take the anti-trump
side as a republican seeking re-election
in 2024 and Trump prevails that could
end up being very damaging to you so
there's a lot of risk here to many in
the Republican party and as we talked
about late last week Republicans are
worried that Trump is going to drag them
down
we now are really starting to look at
trial calendars and Republican debate
schedules and primary schedules and it
is hard to Come Away with any conclusion
other than the one that Newsweek has
come across or come come uh to believe
which is that as they say Donald Trump
is likely to be swamped with multiple
overlapping criminal trials
this is the one scenario other than a
health problem that could derail Donald
Trump's campaign Newsweek writes Donald
Trump is at risk of being faced with
multiple criminal trials at the same
time all while campaigning to become
president in 2024. Tuesday Trump pleaded
not guilty to 37 Federal offenses
connected to the Jack Smith documents
case and is expected to appear next in
Florida Court in June
um it is currently unknown when a trial
could be set for the classified
documents case with the decision to be
made by judge Eileen Cannon of course as
we talked about appointed to the bench
by Trump facing calls to recuse herself
uh the article continues the New York
trial will will take place this is the
other trial the New York trial will take
place while the Republican primary is
well underway and after the so-called
super Tuesday were several States vote
on the same day
elsewhere there have been indications
that the criminal investigation in
Georgia
is drawing to a close and Trump could
face former indictments that's going to
be
um sometime between July and September
probably here they're talking about July
and August Etc afani Willis's office
says federal indictments will not have
any impact on the Fulton County election
investigation saying what she is doing
is going to happen regardless of what is
happening federally and then it's also
important to remember
that Donald Trump is
um potentially going to be federally
indictment indicted an additional time
related to January 6th so when we think
about what could derail Trump a health
problem but that could happen to anybody
anybody could be derailed by a health
problem the political scenario that
could derail Trump is that he is so
flooded with criminal trials that he
quite literally just can't keep
campaigning it pulls him off the
campaign Trail Trump has pledged to stay
in regardless that is his pledge but
Trump says things all the time that end
up not being true this is really a
cautionary Tale it's best to commit only
one crime per year so that you can keep
your schedule clear I'm sort of kidding
of course Trump is innocent until proven
guilty I still doubt at the end of the
day
that the path away from Trump in this
primary is that he drops out uh I
believe or that the path out of trump in
this election is that he drops out I see
it as far more likely that Trump stays
in wins the primary but loses to Joe
Biden in 2024 I believe that is the most
likely scenario the second most likely
scenario is Trump stays in the primary
but loses the primary less likely but
still possible and I believe the least
likely scenario uh is that Donald Trump
bails on the primary and even less
likely I think it's Trump dies and is no
longer a candidate I would put that as
forth that's my order for this at the
end of the day
it really is up to Republicans to decide
what it is that they want and right now
although the polling is moving a little
bit and we're I know we're going to look
at polling later this week
the polling is moving a little bit but
Trump is still very much in control
Chris Christie's argument is when you
talk to the Trump supporters today
about half of them or more say I do
support Trump as of today but I'm open
to supporting somebody else Chris
Christie's argument is if you take the
people who are definitely not supporting
Trump in the primary and then you add to
that the number of people supporting
Trump but willing to vote for someone
else that's enough to win and Chris
Christie is correct mathematically the
question is what would it take for that
group that says I support Trump but I'm
willing to look elsewhere what would it
take to get them to actually look
elsewhere and even two more indictments
I don't believe is going to change their
mind we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P take a listen
to this hey David this is Mike from
Sacramento I just want to say like one I
like your show alive too
um the last four family gatherings that
I've had uh like my right wing relatives
all they talk about all they talk about
is like transgender sex like how much
they hate to you know
the different you know whatever there's
like one one uh transgender woman that
beats people in like swimming and that's
all they talk about that's the most
important thing in the entire world yep
um that in like black mermaids and black
people shouldn't be in any movies
basically so I think listen folks Santa
Claus is white and mermaids are white
why can't these wokesters understand
that like this next election we need to
be prepared for any response that can we
can do regarding those types of things
yeah I think like Chris Christie even
though I agree he does sound pretty
smart to me and to you
um they the Republicans don't care about
that stuff anymore they don't care about
taxes or foreign policy all they care
about is culture wars so I think we have
to have good responses for that stuff my
response to them was it's like they're
saying oh we're concerned that um
transgender people are just going into
women's dress dressing rooms to rape
them well guess what Donald Trump went
into a dressing room dressed as a man
and he raped somebody so they can't you
know using that as sexually assaulted
hold on a second hold on it's like let's
be clear uh no the caller is I mean
that's crazy that and it is incredible
that these are the conversations you
know at one point the sort of
Thanksgiving conversations were very
politically uh stressful but they were
about like tax policy and foreign policy
now it's about black mermaids and that
is that is a really crazy commentary
about where we are today folks we've got
a Bonus show coming up right after this
show make sure you're subscribed at
joinpakman.com to get instant access to
the bonus show we've got an incredible
week of shows coming up I will be at a
wedding on the west coast we've got a
great cast of fill-ins and then I'm
going to be back with you so strongly so
strongly folks on Monday please be nice
to the guest hosts uh at least to their
face okay you can email me later and
complain but please be nice to their
face uh we'll see you on the bonus show
and then everything just continues
throughout the rest of the week